je me demande ce qui se passe dans la
tête des chats par exemple j'ai acheté
un panier à montchat beau panier de
haute qualité et y dort dans les jours
quand tu cohabite avec un chat il ya des
trucs que tu peux pas faire tu peux pas
faire tu es là c est devant l'ordi
tranquille tu peux pas faire à manger
est absente et plus de deux minutes ou
avoir un canapé en bon état enfin ça
c'est impossible
au début tu l'empêchent de faire ses
griffes sur le canapé mais au bout de
4800 faut te le répète tu dis juste aux
habitants pigera canapé de merde moi je
vis avec mon chat on est intime et un
chasse à apa le chromosome de la gêne
ils sont jamais gênés
des fois il fait des trucs merlan tu
partais de me regarder stopper là ça ça
me bloque marché pas les humains ils
font jamais ce à quoi david pourquoi tu
me regardes là parce que j'aime bien
si tu as un chat je pense que tu connais
et que tu utilise régulièrement cet
objet le verrou lorrain va se voir tous
les jours avant de sortir de chez moi
bah moi je me roule que le corps ce truc
là ça rend fou ça devient toc
moi je relate to parfois même jeu
roulotte les poils perdu de mon chat
directement sur mon chat
bon après faut pas trop le faire non
plus bonjour je suis actuellement à une
couille les chats ils font toujours des
trucs trop marrant mais dès que je sors
ton téléphone pour les filmer ils ont
peur les arrête du coup c'est très rare
d'avoir une vidéo vraiment marrant de
plongée j'ai presque envie de poser une
caméra de surveillance pour voir ce
qu'il fait quand je suis pas là on s'en
va et on l'est on gère tout seul pour
voir s'il fait des trucs de ouf pendant
que j'ai pas là c'est parti
j'éteins la lumière un chat et un chien
c'est vraiment pas pareil c'est quand tu
rentres chez toi avec tes un chien ton
chien vraiment il te fait la fête et eux
qui fixent au dessus de l'ena
oui mais l'onu
quand tu rentres chez toi avec ta un
chat c'est pas la même ambiance limite
c'est toi qui lui fait la fête quoi
c'est vrai quand on y pense les chiens y
en a qui ont un métier quoi il ya des
chiens pompiers chien flic chien de la
montagne qui sauvent des vies chiens
guides pour aveugles
alors que les chats au maximum de leurs
compétences il joue avec un bouchon je
suis désolé mais c'est des grosses
merdes
même si j'adore les chats gens pas trop
ce qui pourrait faire comme métier
chercher un boulot
ok je regardais un peu votre cv alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a un niveau des
compétences pisser sur la moquette boire
l'eau sale de la vaisselle réveiller les
gens à 6h du mat
bon c'est pas fifty un jeu et un cerf
avec vous ce que vous pouvez faire
actuellement c'est que dalle donc si tu
es affaires situation des petites
moustaches et à petit que et tu vas te
casser d'accord suivant ah si des fois
mon chef me ramène des cadeaux qu'il a
trouvée à l'extérieur mais c'est des
cadeaux avec sa vision à lui même a fait
un nouveau petit cadeau un de
vers de terre dégueulasse tout amar est
de le tuer wesh j'aimerais bien qu'un
jour et me ramène un truc qui me soit
vraiment utile
c'est pour moi c'est un petit cadeau
c'est trop mignon
impossible à ben génial j'espère que
vous êtes bien foutus de ma gueule
refaites j'ai une surprise pour
vous mon canard de mettre à utiliser
sérieux tu de monnaie pour m'acheter
plein d'objets web de fête pour chat ça
tue sa mère mais la vidéo est encore à
montage
alors je vous balance un petit teaser
allez je vous laisse je dois me lécher
le cul bénit le canapé ciao
[Musique]
tous
pour
[Musique]